le soir du dramatique incendie qui a
ravagé notre dame de paris le chef de
l'état s'est engagé à une restauration
complète de la cathédrale dans un délai
de cinq ans j'avais alors penser qu'une
émotion bien légitime d'ailleurs avait
occulté un réalisme de bon aloi
compte tenu de l'absence totale de
diagnostic quant aux dommages subis
mais cette détermination affichée s'est
confirmée dans les jours qui ont suivi
par le dépôt d'un projet de loi rédigé à
la hâte
pourvu d'une étude d'impact sommaire et
souris à une procédure accélérée
or ce texte opère des choix qui
m'apparaissent aussi étonnant que
dangereux outre qu'il confie la mission
de reconstruction un établissement
public créé pour l'occasion
alors que l'opinion le cmn seraient des
opérateurs tout à fait compétent pour ce
rôle il prévoit dans son article 9 je
cite des mesures d'aménagement et de
dérogation en matière d'urbanisme
d'environnement de construction et de
préservation du patrimoine sur le
ministre de quel aménagement est qu'elle
des grosses des relations s'agira-t-il
la production de nos monuments
historiques est assurée par un ensemble
de lois et de règles déontologiques issu
d'une très longue tradition française la
france figure parmi les pionniers en la
matière il serait très périlleux
d'initier des dérogations qui plus est
par voie d'ordonnancé moyens redoutable
d'éviter le débat
la france dispose par ailleurs des
meilleurs spécialistes de la protection
du patrimoine y compris dans votre
ministère
je m'interroge donc également sur le
concours international d'architecturé
envisagée pour reconstruire la flèche de
la cathédrale
prenons garde monsieur le ministre
qu'après avoir connu loutre âge des
flammes
l'intégrité de notre dame soit pas mise
à mal par des innovations visant à la
rendent selon l'expression même du
président de la république plus belle
encore et à votre avis que veut dire
dans ce contexte cette expression plus
belle encore
la parole est à m le propriétaire
ministre de la culture madame la
présidente mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur leleux lundi 15
avril
nous étions tous bouleversés par les
images que nous avons vues de notre dame
de paris en flammes et je dois dire et
vous le savez bien que sans le travail
extraordinaire le courage la compétence
et le sang froid des sapeurs pompiers de
paris
le drame aurait pu être bien pire qu'il
n'a été lundi et je dois dire que depuis
lundi aussi le travail des équipes du
ministère de la culture a permis en lien
avec les sapeurs pompiers de paris mais
aussi avec des sapeurs pompiers de toute
l'ile-de-france de sécuriser de
sécuriser notre dame de paris pour
éviter pardon excusez moi de d'éviter
que les drames soient plus grave encore
depuis nous avons pris rapidement au
salon de dispositions notamment à
travers la loi que nous allons vous
soumettre pour faire en sorte d'avoir un
dispositif notamment fiscales
spécifiques pour accompagner
l'engouement des français
la générosité des français si la
question concerne la loi la générosité
des français pour notre dame de paris et
nous avons omis et nous allons pouvoir
en débattre ensemble un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui nous permettront
d'avoir le meilleur dispositif
législatif pour restaurer de la
meilleure façon possible notre dame de
paris
nous en discuterons ensemble mais je
suis le garant des principes
fondamentaux du pres de prêt à mettre de
la préservation du patrimoine et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour avec les
équipes du ministère de la culture
les architectes en chef des monuments
historiques les architectes des
bâtiments de france qui oeuvrent en ce
moment même sur notre dame de paris à
notre dame de paris que tout que tous
les dispositifs qui vise à préserver le
patrimoine seront respectés pour notre
dame de paris
mais monsieur le sénateur ne nous
privons pas de dispositif qui nous
permettrait effectivement de restaurer
notre dame de paris à la hauteur de ce
qu'est notre dame de paris pour toute
l'humanité
concernant concernant la flèche laissons
la créativité se
laissons la créativité des architectes
s'exprimer et le moment venu nous
déciderons de restaurer à l'identique ou
de restaurer en tenant compte de ces
gestes architecturaux